REPORTS, MANY UKRAINIANS IN
KHARKIV ARE SHELTERING
UNDERGROUND AFTER TAKING REFUGE
MORE THAN TWO MONTHS AGO.
>> Reporter: THE NOISES MAY BE
FURTHER AWAY FROM KHARKIV.
BUT PART OF THE CITY STILL STAYS
HIDDEN UNDERGROUND, IN THE
SUBWAYS.
THEY CAME DOWN TO SHELTER JUST
FOR THE NIGHT, BUT THAT WAS TWO
MONTHS AGO.
HOMES NOW DESTROYED, THE FEAR OF
THE BOMBS REMAINING.
MOST HAVE NOWHERE TO GO.
OFFICIALS HAVE ASKED PEOPLE TO
LEAVE SOON, AND STOPPED PEOPLE
SLEEPING, AT LEAST IN THE
TRAINS, WHICH THEY HAVE TO GET
MOVING AGAIN.
THIS WOMAN KEEPS HER PLACE TIDY
AND WELCOMING, BUT IS ALONE
HERE.
HER FLAT BOMBED TWICE.
>> Reporter: IN THE DAMP COLD,
WITH FOOD IN ONE BUCKET, URINE
IN ANOTHER, THIS IS A
DESPERATION RUSSIA'S WAR ON
UKRAINE WANTED TO INFLICT.
SHE SAT BETWEEN HER FAMILY AND
PEOPLE WHOSE NAME SHE DOESN'T
EVEN KNOW.
EVEN IF UKRAINE WINS, THIS IS
STILL WHERE IT HURTS, IN THE
LOSS OF PRESUMPTIONS ABOUT THE
MOST ORDINARY PARTS OF LIFE.
VICTOR IS SHELTERING IN A GAME
OF TWO PIRATE SHIPS ATTACKING
EACH OTHER.
WE SEE SOME DECIDING TO LEAVE
ALREADY.
YET STILL THE FRAMEWORK OF
PERMANENT SETS IN.
AND THE OUTSIDE, SUNNIER DAYS
TURN NOISY AT NIGHT.
UKRAINE OFFICIALS, WHILE THEY
SEEM TO WANT PEOPLE OUT OF THE
METRO, ARE SUGGEST AS A PLAN TO
HOUSE THEM IN DORMITORIES.
BUT KHARKIV, WHILE IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS UNDER
PRESSURE THAN IT WAS A MATTER OF
WEEKS AGO, STILL AT 4:00 A.M.
YESTERDAY, A ROCKET HIT CLOSE TO
WHERE I'M STANDING.
STILL TONIGHT, WE HEAR WHAT
SOUNDS LIKE OUTGOING SHELLING
AND OF COURSE, THE FIGHTING
STILL RELATIVELY CLOSE TO THE
CITY CENTER.
INTENSIFICATION, THOUGH, IN THE
MORE CENTRAL PART OF EASTERN
UKRAINE, AS RUSSIA APPEARS TO BE
MAKING MINIMAL GAINS THERE.
AND YOU MENTIONED EXTRA U.S.
AID.
ANOTHER $100 MILLION ANNOUNCED
WILL BE RUSHED INTO HERE.
THAT MAY TIP THE BALANCE IN THE
LONGER TERM IN UKRAINE'S FAVOR.